come to LA we found a nice little juice
bar you get some some green machines
some juices some grill food arrived
beautiful tropical breeze look at that
apples I mean we can need to get more of
this in our systems definitely ah come
to LA we found a nice spot where we are
now this is called core email this is
where all the missing restaurants are so
they call it core email any from the D
show is here on curry Maya
[Music]
we're here at a must job as a pre her
tomorrow sir as traveling it's a nice
little lecture going on he's talking
about the rights of the neighbor says
you know they're just talking about
Muslims no just talk about Christian
whatever neighbor you have the process
haven't said so its army general he
didn't distinguish and then what did he
say that that whoever what someone who
annoys their neighbor will not enter
gently and some same thing if you go to
sleep with your belly full believer
you're not a true believer in them
that's deep so you don't want a Muslim
neighbor so the process is this is
amazing to behavior how you find in
England
so wet in the wet some rain but no it's
doubt but it's nice but it's warmer than
Chicago for sure yeah after New Year you
start to get the January blues yeah you
know people start getting depressed then
now they've did the credit card bill has
come through the door and they realized
it just wasted a little money I've got a
lot of a lot of debt yeah
and this is when people start to reflect
on life and you find a lot of people the
for instance you get a lot of suicides
lot of suit yeah young you a February
you know the January blues and so so on
this time yeah that's what you see what
what you were saying is you know people
um you know when that bill kicks in it's
interesting where you have the saying
that people are buying things that they
don't need with money they don't have
some press people yeah they don't even
like